hopla premier scream art bienvenue dans
ce troisième épisode de notre laiterie
sur outlast 2 c'est parti alors la
mecque je crois qu'on venait de faire
des courses poursuites de ouf c'était
horrifique voilà comme tout ce qui se
passe dans ce plan de jeu à sortir la
caméra va se mentir je crois qu'on
tombait dans un endroit genre ben voilà
c'est exactement cet endroit a envoyé
voilà là on est en train de faire du
malgache et là je suppose que c'est ici
que la magie opère des chaises pour un
public
je voulais seulement vu par la suite je
n'aurais pas pu un [ __ ] il en dit
tellement peu c'est horrible bon nous
c'est ça ne dit pas aux faucons haye a
faut qu'on pousse ça ok 9 je devrai bien
emmener m'étais attaché je suis désolé
et j'avoue je suis un père oui j'ai
pensé à ma peau un peu alors pas se
mentir on va passer par là nous on a on
a une c'est cru ces conneries une autre
femme a sauvés c'est une fausse
où j'étais cadavres c'est une fausse
talent j'avais peur guerre mais qui
arrive par derrière tu sais j'étais pas
bien on va mais même si tu tombes
relatés dans le mal on va tomber c'est
évident c'est toujours ça où tu l'as on
va tout mais il ya un mec qui va arriver
de là bas je ne sache pas pourquoi ça
paul fume pas non c'est bon y'a pas il a
rien à commenter au [ __ ] quelle est
donc cette terrible ça fout la frousse à
ses petits sont de vieux moulin qui
m'attend alors oui je vais plus utiliser
la caméra puisque vous permet de mieux
voir en plus sur les vidéos j'ai
vraiment lu tous vos commentaires donc
j'ai essayé de faire du mieux que je
peux alors nouvelle maison wright dans
monte personne ça fleurit à personne a
priori à personne bord au nom en pitié
oh non non quand je monte donc je monte
en pitié oh ça commence d'entrée de jeu
quoi il a lâché un gros il est dans la
maison il a lâché un gros ils étalent
étages sans parler de tout ce qui est
produits laitiers bien sûr c'est drôle
ça ok du coup on descend à à ok faut
s'en aller par là je suppose ça s'est
tellement le stress est construite là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
t'as rien du tout bon pote ok on va
aller tout droit à gauche tu as un plus
bas non ils peuvent te suivent alors que
tu roules cette terrible mon gars ça met
une pression supplémentaire
la super nes moins un titre qui claque
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà par là par là par la junte à
la hausse
[Applaudissements]
omer bhatti 8 424 sommes casteu seule
pièce faut que j'aille ses parents j'ai
35 ans durant
ok on a réussi on a réussi à s'échapper
tout va bien tout va bien il y aura
percé dans cette maison parce qu'on a
beaucoup de chance un de notre malheur
on a la chance dans notre malheur mais
on est tellement de malchance de notre
femme qui s'est fait kidnapper et mise
enceinte spectre ok manière mettre
ensemble j'arrive pas alors c'est pas
beau du tout ce qui se passe au quai des
reflets à mais qu est ce que ça fait une
image d'archivé lui lui il est pas mort
lui s'il respire pas et bon il est
totalement mort ce qui nous met pas
forcément en confiance ça on va pas se
mentir
beauvais cette porte c'est terrible oh
oh ça fait penser à au cauchemar que
j'avais avec la classe de de musique là
bon s'il faut que je filme ouais donc by
fred you're going to heaven ne soit pas
n'ai pas peur tu vas aller au paradis je
mourrais sportel
ce que je perds la tête un peu aller
aussi elf avant qu'il tue les enfants
tu aurais de jeu mais mais qu'est ce que
je fais [ __ ] les mecs ça me met le bas
de ses vidéos là ça me met vraiment
gbagbo en tout cas je vais pas oublier
de le faire dans cet épisode peut
compter sur moi j'ai essayé de filmer
tout ce qui bouge alors du coup on va où
ce c'est bien beau cet endroit malsain à
balard je pense à way et des escaliers
qui montent fonce en france on décale
lumière j'ai besoin c'est des mecs qui
tiennent des lampes torches ça m'effraie
mon gars c'est terrible j'ai jamais
entendu que j'étais effrayée mais c'est
considérable à une note attention encore
un truc de fou objectif les enfants ne
doivent pas craindre leur devoir mais le
célébrer comme un accès garanti au
paradis
d'accord souvenez vous il n'ya pas de
vouloir paradis papa vous a donné la vie
et votre vie lui à partir au combat et à
l'est par la fenêtre ou pas en fait
c'est merde j'ai pas le choix pour
sortir alors petit bandages et on est
bien
voilà un moteur cry on est bien il ya
plus de blessure en blessure qui
tiennent alors par où dois-je aller
je te file baisse annoncée bon par la
haye à une note encore à quoi servent
ces demandes maman madame karlsson a dit
que je peux pas te dire ce qu'ils vont
faire mais elle a pas dit que je pouvais
pas écrire je t'en prie ne laisse pas me
tuer je t'aime et j'aime papa giuliana
[ __ ] memex horrible ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont tué des enfants des [ __ ] de
georges peut atteindre cet endroit
[ __ ] de clôture il suffit de monter
sur quelque chose
ok je vais trouver ça ça va ça ça va
pousser ça ça c'est une bonne idée ou
pas est-ce qu'on a une bonne idée mais
bien sûr regardez quelle bonne idée
gloria aider à vouloir tout plein de
gens maintenant ou gauche d'accord je
pense pour préciser ça mais ça ne me dit
rien de bon un millier neuf là juste là
en fait avec ça qu'ils nous as one shot
dans deux hôpitaux aux [ __ ] on n'est
pas bien du tout la mecque en vrai on
n'est pas bien du tout hélas et ferment
passer par la gauche direct allez vas-y
fais partie on y va on y croit
ça pousse pas du tout par la beauté est
peut-être suis en train de faire la
bêtise de ma vie je ne sais point à
temps interagir tout interagir non je
peux pas interdire un jeu plus je me
cachais d'accord c'est pas la même chose
facile oh non non pas roux c'est [ __ ]
je sais pas par où aller ces immenses
mais où veux tu que j'aille à la fin on
part là je tente un match polaire jeu
totalement perdu dans mes pensées
autant que dans le jeu sauvegarde acheté
par la ola [ __ ]
ça va ça marche du temps ces saloperies
je sois allé de là d'où elle vient à mon
avis déjà
eux ça va faire mal comme l'un des
clichés volés ou bordel avec sa pioche
la d20 mines et du cuivre et des sports
un [ __ ] faut pas aller là
[ __ ] mais merde je me cache mes gars
je suis pas là tu m'as pas vu je sais
pas où aller c'est à sauvegarder vers là
peut-être par là ok je l'espère je
l'espère je l'espère on est bien je
laisse mais je sais pas comment j'ai
fait mais je laisse les mecs je fais un
tour deux pas des deux pâtés de maison
elle n'en pouvait plus
je regardais à moi plus je regarde c'est
bon là elle arrive pas elle arrive pas
on est bien on est bien on est bien en
alternant jeu long et large
[ __ ] c'est loin de la porte au privé
c'est bon il s'est barré on a de la
chance mon gars allez salage obtiendra
bien qu au lalalalalala quelle histoire
mais quelle histoire oh là là là là je
suis désolé pour vous aimez ça fait un
paquet d'années que des sports à mon
avis bon moi j'ai ma femme a trouvé
l'hymne li ning line ce que je peux
entrer choper des piles à peut-être
tient peut-être peut-être y at-il une
pile dans cet endroit jusqu'à je vais
commencer à manquer de piles mais ne
rien il ya des [ __ ] j'en peux plus
avec des croix inversée bien évidemment
à une pile hockey [ __ ] je fais bien
dire vous commencez à vous écouter
regarder grâce à vous je trouve débile
j'apprends des trucs en plus j'ai pas vu
c'est horrible elle est là la chapelle
la chapelle une chapelle est censé être
un sanctuaire
d'accord ce qui veut dire que ce n'est
pas un sanctuaire la main
allez on monte trois assez imposant
alors une chapelle est censé être un
sanctuaire je me demande ce qu'on va
découvrir devant cette porte mac mais à
bas pour le prophète qui ne s'était pas
il ya un mec qui siens ya un gardien non
mais c'est sûr je dis pas ça pour vous
effrayer mais c'est plus pour vous
notes et là je m'appelle plec étrangers
le père fils père de personne j'ai juste
tuer moi je vais me mais non mais non
provient avec mory les lui fera du mal
jeudi à et où il n'aura aucune raison de
lui faire du mal
mais que je suis je sais pas quoi ça va
il ya d'écrit il ya d'écrit merde dans
sa tête et derrière il ya des cris de là
bas on va juste barcia pas assez pour se
cacher aux [ __ ] se cache là dedans
quoi un sauvegarde tu me dis qu'il
fallait se cacher nous l'avons trouvé
elle essayait de s'enfuir
parmi les galeux ce ne sont pas là des
actions d'une femme à la confiance imac
réponse à ton compagnon majeur il ne te
voit pas fait la réponse
sept îles orkney et autres jeux est la
vanité aussi la femme étrangère cache la
destruction de ce monde dans son ventre
n'est pas laisser sa peau stars ont volé
l'ennemi avec le frère du démon s'était
jamais son immonde eurécole de drames
loi ce n'est à mon lot nous disposons
seulement de quelques heures pour la
retrouver dès la 10è et ainsi sauver ce
paradis de l'enfer éternel
où est elle vous voilà qui est le mien
je peux pas c'est pour toi jeudi un
véhicule
le vent ce qui a pris qu'ils ont fuies
force et l on se rappelle me demander
qui réunit des monnaies dites à josiane
arrêté que n'entend pas les pécheresses
[ __ ] il va se faire démolir
[Applaudissements]
je vais parler d'eux mêmes
or die
je n'ai pas
les femmes j'ai mis dans la montagne va
l'emmener dans les mines on vous la
trouverez jamais avant la naissance
non donc lyn et dans les mines dans les
montagnes d'accord très bien il faut
qu'on aille dans les mines avant eux
bon on va pouvoir y aller ouais il faut
qu'on aille aux mines mike bon tant pis
je filme lui a pas moyen de séquences à
faire au mes mecs c'est d'une violence
soit et dans les mines lavit
ils font toujours du mal aux femmes pour
punir les hommes
ces malades lâche pas je te fais pas
dire mon gars allez on sort il faut
qu'on aille dans les mines comment on va
dans les mines faut repartir par là
elle et elle est à hockey musical
parfait d'accord elle est vraiment sur
un tuyau torture coups que je me casse
alors la mecque on va essayer de se
concentrer
il était la chapelle et bien qu'on
n'aura pas ça il pourra près de ouf donc
je pense que c'est par là à mon avis
c'est à gauche ici là annonça
ok c'est bon ça l'a fait avec j'ai
tellement eu peur de faire choper on
s'en réclament
par là on monte les marches avec au togo
ne suis pas encore là
non c'est bon à 6 arrive [ __ ] je les
ai vus à les bâtards ils sont en bas
allez casse pas les mêmes vues ces mecs
ok on est bien
coc mer deux sont toujours là alors ils
sont là [ __ ] t'es ma le high et plus
larges voies plus aux [ __ ] à la
pression demant la pile j'ai pas vu
juste en c'est [ __ ] une fois que lui à
bâle et par là aux mecs on saute ça et
il est temps d'avancer mon gars [ __ ]
alors par où on doit aller une fois
qu'on est là on a une pile ça ça ouais
faut dire ce qui est bien là une pile on
est on est bien on est mieux que si on
n'avait pas être pile et ça me permettra
à utiliser souvent la caméra pour que
vous voyez quelque chose hein mais c'est
quand vous voyez rien sur youtube quand
je mets pas la caméra moi non plus je
vois rien genre là et moi je vois quasi
rien tu vas y perd son mec
[Musique]
dehors toi mon petit enfant
est-ce qu est-ce que je base derrière
elle a pas l'air méchant temps ses
enfants jusque ont été tuées quoi donc
elle et toi tu irais je dis pas que je
restais là tu écoutais avis quand même
mais est à palerme et chante
j'espère vraiment que le besoin
d'acheter les toits on sent photos
allaient [ __ ] [ __ ] faut que je
m'échappe par la fenêtre dans les champs
allez-y go ok là je vois rien
typiquement je vois rien mais
typiquement il va falloir qu'on fasse
quelque chose
ah c'est tout début du jeu en fait là
souvenez de ce mec c'est tout début du
[ __ ] de dieu mec
olala c'est une catastrophe de ce qu'on
voit là ça brise le moral ça je rentre
mais moi je serai pas repéré au moins -
eux et mes abonnés sera pas un arrêt
cardiaque
tu évites lui il est pas loin du bruit
contraire c'est pour moi y'a pas
d'autres solutions que je traversais
faut aller au bourg
mais pas pas d'autre choix à la
possibilité votée assez chiant ça je me
couvrir pas être vite
[Musique]
moi ok on parle de machettes de
qualitair on parle de machettes de
qualité trois passes mito bois il est
tellement proches ce bâtard à mon avis
il faut escalader lapalissade que ya là
pour accéder au chant de l'autre côté
qui lui donnera bien vers nous là
quant à le scandaleux ok maintenant faut
y aller on a fait faire cramer
on se fait grave et on se fait grave et
je me rends jamais
nous courons après
messieurs fou sauf qu'au parlement oh
[ __ ] une clôture
c'est quoi ça non ce n'est pas nouvelle
non franchement il ya une manivelle à
trouver mec c'est le pire truc qui
pouvait nous arriver
y a pas pire y a pas pire réellement
elle est là angéla marival
attends je me soigne faut que je me
soigne h bandage h autour de touche son
histoire est au moins aussi informer que
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
allez on y va avec
s'il est là c'est un vieux gars ok ça me
garde aller à manivelle
et maintenant comment j'y vais comment
j'y vais comme ça on va à mon avis c'est
la toile et la voilà c'est bon je
trouvais voilà exactement comme ça allez
on s'enfuit le truc c'est qu'il rend pas
non c'est pas tard par là on est bien en
bas ok toi tu animes une vache morte à
droite c'est ça nickel eye ase s'ils
viennent pas les mecs se découragent ça
fait très plaisir
[ __ ] une pile elle est à moi elle
m'appartient ces maps il faut que
j'aille ou bon on va suivre les airs
mais qu'un pas se mentir
ok ça nous redirige [ __ ] mais ces
animaux morts partout mais j'en peux
plus et une maison est ce que c'est le
web c'est par là qu'il faut aller un
trou s'est parlé à mon avis
alors qu'est cette maison une note on
les prend toutes les notes mais qu
auriez su une pile à serge c'est un truc
annexes wozzeck gendreau il ya des piles
en vrai suivi des endroits annexes faut
pas y aller bah ouais bon on a bien fait
mais quand on a gagné une pile en
dessous d'eux on s'est mis bien si c'est
palace tout droit d'un de merde à me
frayer un chemin
olala faut arrêter aussi eu des acquis
et mannequin pourra être pris à bandage
terme star données utilisées c'est nous
faire du bien on est où là
dans une ferme à une ferme dans ce qui
reste d'une ferme
ordre a passé la porte ouais mais qu'est
ce qu'il me faut s'accrocher où je peux
trouver ça mec bons magasins en amérique
rocher est pas là ce serait beaucoup
trop simple donc on va se bouger tue pas
mais l'ouvrir mieux que ça annonce a
fait exprès [ __ ] je me fais penser ça
va être horrible alors la maison à
droite on a déjà fait
c'est par la presse que ça de façon
franchement par là
[Applaudissements]
mais pâques avec son flair elle me sens
et elle va venir vers la pitié va-t'en
negras
va-t'en va-t'en viens pas dit un mot
revient pas néanmoins battre s'en va
bien loin bien loin
à la lutte tout attoumane après je sais
pas elle donne le la
ok on est sûr mais sauvé par là ok c'est
bon oh [ __ ] le petit ou que vous avez
bien on arrive où là je suis désolé mec
je suis désolé mais je suis désolé
j'essaie de même puisque la sexualité
c'était parce qu'on a accroché
éventuellement abondée beaucoup chela a
bola on a décroché le beau crochet si je
puis me permettre à ge pourrait sortir
par l'aspect nourrissent des simples en
attendant il faut que j'aille dedans à
de la viande accroché à sécher décroché
à travers leur talent days
[ __ ] c'est dégueulasse bon est-ce que
ce copinage que quand même prendre un
crochet qui mérite bien accrochée après
avoir vu tout ça en vrai nom mais en
vrai il y en a c'est sûr y'a bien
accroché pour lucas hashtag un crochet
pour lucas sbp est à arriver là regardez
là où ok c'est bon on a un crochet pièce
y'a plus qu'à retourner à l'autre
endroit et on est bon je m'appuie cm
[Applaudissements]
je me casse un vrai
[Musique]
le catalan je me casse est très très
très lent
c'est par où j'étais passé à ce que
lâche moi c'était ici c'était la fois
que je joue à cache-cache maghreb pas se
mentir
je peux aller
je ne sais pas
où est cette [ __ ] de dames pour mais
quinze ans on y va on peut aller franco
comme james
mais tu vas voir une cible pour faire
ton délire avec le crochet j'ai pas ce
que tu as comme idée en tête refn of
tweets et maintenant on la chaîne est
juste la jetant au cou make me laisse
trop tard déjà
ces tests sont voilà allez au revoir
n'aura plus haut
ouais voilà dans le prochain épisode
à bientôt pour l'épisode iv merci
d'avoir regardé au revoir les années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on